a cosec opção
até o momento não houve nada pois não há
intenção de matar - a presença de
ninguém não sou o técnico
eles são joão vai pisar no serviço de
chamadas o zeca urubu culpa do nosso t
que nós contarmos ganhava uma paisagem
nawa é nós montarmos o o zeca eo zeca
tem tema genérico é especialmente uma
homenagem oficial o zeca afonso é e esta
é a questão na josé afonso acontece
porque tudo é capaz de gravar e é um dos
fatos mais difícil e agora o que fazer e
melhorado e muitas vezes escolhido é e
avança em uma única máquina faca
quer dizer que o josé karina chegou a
gravar o primeiro está no compacto que
kadafi metástico liga e nós achamos que
são os que têm custado nosso ano nossa
apresentação já teve falta agora o
comando de confinados é então nós nós
criamos o nosso pensar ainda aponta como
uma pequena homenagem que podemos fazer
achamos que existem portugueses são boas
em avaré que não são conhecidos e que
toda a gente deveria mostrar o que tava
quer ver acontecerem avalia que os
outros fizessem vir até nós
everton então quando seu carro no
momento faz loucura dizer isso foi por
aí
nós devemos criar um espaço aí que
poderia começar sua teoria porque os
passos já existir é e também em um
problema que nos sentimos em haviam
poucos passos de ter mais alternativas
que o nosso espécie de incentivarem
fosse uma cafeteria quase uma sala de
estar e e como nós passamos muito tempo
em lisboa no porto em coimbra e em todos
esses locais há muito espaço nesse tipo
de avaria no avião e único que ele
chamava se inscrito só para achar e na
altura quando houve uma publicação de
escutas equipe fecharia caramba como é
que é possível o unique passei a ver que
é complementar o trânsito vai achar não
pode não pode fechar e então fui ter com
um nissan é nem mais gostoso é que nem
sempre dizer que se não a coisa não
funcionou em casa é e eu tinha uma idéia
da epa gm se calhar podíamos ficar com
biscoitos ela está no boca que eu cite
funcionário não funciona e passar pra
frente
o motivo dela já estava no lucro porque
na altura nós tenhamos havia 3 com três
meses é e como é filha de três meses e
com outros dois anos já expôs temos mais
ou menos juízo e chá que vamos fazer
outra coisa que já são os nossos
trabalhos todos nós trabalhamos
olha tem o nosso projeto era mais ou
menos três filhos investir três filhos
temos 2010 e vamos proibir é e ela cai
de estágios fazer ficar durante um ano
com com zeca e e vamos ver se funciona
os funcionários vão funcionar flash e
voltamos a idéia de ter o outro filho
que já tem não sair ileso ou do art
zeca não correr bem bahia salvador então
pode ser bonita mesmo
não está escrito importante já não é já
é difícil então isso era realmente o
momento que nós tínhamos que tomar a
decisão que tomámos a decisão de ir para
frente pensar não temos que criar alguma
coisa que seja diferente e temos que ser
um pouco mais dinâmicos que os demais
que nós tenhamos um problema grave é que
teria já existia em aracaju há cerca de
cinco anos e ninguém conhecia ninguém se
o biscoito era um espaço muito lixo e
então as pessoas algumas delas sem o
conhecimento entrar lá pensaram que era
autista que era extremamente ligado à
cultura então tinham medo de entrar e
está a ser o índice uma casa antiga
estrada antiga tipografia que foi
recuperada e nós não temos que abrir as
portas ao povo a primeira ação fizemos
foi convidar os vizinhos todos a virem
ter connosco e eu preciso ter fé e
xavantinho ter connosco quando conheceu
o espaço mulher que esteja legal como
nós tínhamos um problema de ninguém que
serão 180 que inventar histórias a
primeira foi o zeca afonso foi claro na
história do zeca afonso a gente
perguntando quem é que eu sei que vamos
usar o que tem aqui um diagnóstico logo
moto espalhar a mensagem josé que é o zé
carlos da fonseca mexeu que avaí e é
completamente enganado pelos aveirenses
então o que estã oa nossa história a
segunda história foi aquela velhinha que
apareceu e com a suzana que a nossa
funcionária e me chama sempre bonito
nome também estas conferências mas hoje
está truncado engripado que ela gosta de
sair à sexta à noite então a coisa não
corre muito mas depois mogi não pode vir
aqui se mas ela vai sempre a todas as
conferências que nós fazemos
a linha era um moto que nós precisávamos
para ter mais histórias pra contar
porque por todo o estado este negócio
vivo a volta de comunicação digital
nós os dois anos só a plataforma de
comunicação digital para trazer os
clientes até o zeca para trazer e muitas
vezes nem a questão
em muitos pontos então essa foi a
segunda história que nós pensarmos que
podemos contar era ok
a irmã dela pescadores portanto nós
temos imensa ser linha faz todo sentido
temos uma homenagem amanhã acho que 12 a
celinha espécie que por aqui então
compramos uma salinha gigante com cerca
de dois metros de pachorra importa estou
tirando fotografias com ela recebe mimos
em prendas
ela faz frase no facebook e fala com as
pessoas elas pontos a gente só tem aqui
a maria bonita tem um clube faz
efe essa linha mais famosa da banca
depois começo não chegava porque quer
dizer isso não é bom negócio ao tamanho
do negócio
então nós ficamos em duas áreas
o primeiro foi na área das estrelas
nacionais e pensamos qualquer um seria
lógico que tem a maior quantidade de
cervejas artesanais navalha ou na foto
não todas nós temos pelo menos uns três
quatro cervejas artesanais da van
quando nós falamos agora num avanço para
nós na cidade mais vezes no castelo do
batel brilhava é um erro pensar
pequenininho é quando estamos finalmente
no mundo digital e todos os planos
o nosso mercado da vale é haver completa
o distrito conseguem tudo tem feito toda
vai pra nós é a vale não está legal mas
não é agora que está um pai bater melhor
de tudo avante tudo que for nunca que
existe nós queremos ter
então tivemos e se esse cuidado na
procura destas mas nós temos mais do que
achamos que podemos ter por um contexto
histórico quer suína
por ser a primeira cerveja artesanal
identificada em portugal e nós achamos
que unidos terem também porque go e por
isso ficaremos em fazer produtos que
fossem punidos porque nós sempre seremos
que a influência dos outros é muito
importante então nós criamos uma série
de tudo que tivesse a ver com o tempo
cai de scott quentes um bom aspecto
algumas pessoas querem partilhar
gené na internet e essa estratégia
funcionou perfeitamente
quando nós começamos a fazer uma uma
mudança foi quando percebemos que nós de
negócio não percebemos nada eu e anos o
dobro da área marcos só tudo que sai da
cafeteria atenção nossa fé é cápsula que
nós não se inspirar outros a f8 ópera
enganar o café central am
tanto não há engano eu não sabia que
também não quiseram inventar
então o que é que nós quando começamos
com o negócio os anos para cá teria
linhas de trabalho por muito que as
pessoas digam que eu tenho margem de
lucro total no pina não tem uma margem
de lucro botão dá muito trabalho nós não
temos que encontrar outras coisas então
transformarmos o com zeca e cafeteria
passou a ser uma loja de produtos
tradicionais
continuando sempre perfeito também lojas
de produtos regionais rapidamente virou
uma loja online depois de vir à loja
online começamos a vender passagens
turísticos em havana num - um passeio
turístico base que a china vai passear
de moça isso para nós não é passear
enquanto e são 45 minutos pegando um
autocarro semana
nós fizemos uma passagem grátis em que
abandonou e sai fazendo passar e tem de
fazer é obrigatório é de possibilitar
suína se manter com o seu joão que a
maior nota o mais autêntico davani tudo
enfim dentro da salina que você espera o
inter não jogou pelo milan os presentes
paz amor e itália ainda depois de uma
série de passagens pelos circos dar nova
pelo bairro histórico da bahia mas
queremos que as pessoas chegassem a
variedade e se realmente ficar melhor em
havana existem muitas coisas boas em
havana as pessoas utilizarem haveria uma
cidade para passar um dia não é um livro
de expulsar dois dias 34 quanto vocês
quiserem se quiserem é só pedir um
problema nosso rendimento das atividades
muito 11 vencedores basta ir ao coração
e se unir nessa altura nos visita porque
não é só o sol nesta nesta altura nós
temos uma colônia família deve ficar na
nas salinas só por puri visitar essa
colônia já é algo fabuloso e nós não
tínhamos cá temos bons embora e nunca
mais teve que ser muito
mas enquanto o jogo rápido rabo do gato
rádio am e aí o santos e fazer um texto
passado onde quer um carro nos contatos
histórias no digital não só era melhor
como era mas manter aquilo que nós temos
de fazer muito da estratégia que nós
colocamos aqui em prática também é como
o trabalho do dia a dia que é de todos
candidatos todas as redes sociais e
muitas vezes sou muito limitado pelos
meus clientes utilizem a ponto de fazer
isso após não fazer que o atual
estratégia está certa mas não pode se
avançar porque a empresa não pode fazer
aquelas restrições normativas e eu
sentia muitas vezes a minha estratégia
era ocultada por via de sam decide por
nós que os gostoso e como o direto de
deus e eu sei que essa mulher não gosta
do que eu nem fazia criaram limitações e
personal no zeca com rafael correu mal
eu vou implementar tudo o que acha
correto que quando chegou rápido que
está no facebook não fazia sem ter um
estádio maior ganho em portugal e por
não estarem a impedir esta em uma prece
e criar minha loja online
um dos pontos que passa por todas essas
plataformas é que todas elas são
completamente gratuitas nós não gostamos
nunca estão aí nenhuma plataforma porque
eram as mais rápidas e implementaremos
não tinha dinheiro
nós não somos aquelas tartan fecha a
agonia dos pais não nós não tivermos
fundos não nós primeiro fizemos riscados
e agora vivemos uma pois se joga agora
vale mais a pena já que estamos há um
ano e maio a trabalhar ea gente nós
ganhar
não tivemos à espera de nada para
avançar a primeira passagem estamos
revoltados depois então pode ser que
anos depois tiver espero agora temos que
vencer porque não estamos na cabeça
não há dor e se desse tipo de estratégia
então estamos nestas nestas plataformas
bridge num passe de mágica custou a
entender que nós descobrimos que mais do
que nós criamos plataformas de palha
para as pessoas falarem a outras
plataformas que as próprias pessoas
queriam falar conosco
foi um dos nossos maiores eu estava indo
opção de franquia está aqui na platéia
confira evento ficar ganhou uma lata de
cerveja 74 está aqui olhar pronto é que
eles não sabem o que é e eu temos o rio
o instagram foi a de hoje foi nosso
maior erro nem pensar na estreia mas
acho que não era uma revenda rolante e
quando vimos e hoje em dia nós
entendemos o porquê nem pensamos na
altura a estratégia foi montada em cerca
de estratégia e e encomendação cerca de
uma semana o site estava online com
logotipo com sites loja online tudo
funcionário me estranha é que foi a
raiva de ter um descanso já escolheram
para comunicar conosco e nós ainda não
estamos lá tripas mais e foi um dos fãs
especialmente brasileiros começaram a
identificar o zeca como um caldo
francini avaliou o cara espetacular
então vamos para o hotel enquanto varzim
magia com portugal é também irmão é ela
que era parte importante das imagens a
fim de ter uma estratégia de comunicação
é bem vai do yale e oco muito do que do
que passou na nossa estratégia foi
passar muito pouco produto muito pouco
produto é mais ou menos as calças temos
uma duas três quatro publicações mais
divertidas muito mais do que criar
entretenimento como se faz e depois
tivemos uma do produto que mesmo assim é
contextualizado com o espaço que o linux
4 5º com scott tudo o resto eram ou
frase que eram enviados pelos pelos fãs
ou então momento fã da maria bonita que
ela anda por todo mundo é honesto as
pessoas
ele então ela sempre por aí e esse tipo
de publicação as pessoas não ficassem no
meio das redes sociais as pessoas e para
isso nós estamos nas redes sociais ea um
erro crasso nesta parte das redes
sociais das empresas querem estar
pensando mais quentes como sendo redes
promocionais e não redes sociais
então as pessoas que vão ao facebook com
a associação desaba passatempo não bom
ver um catálogo de produtos ninguém quer
mesmo
luta constante - então nós temos que
apresentam sempre ser usadas nos níveis
de seus planos
pensamos é que eu tenho que ter
realmente um sorriso e bezarra osec
sentimento positivo é algo que olha olha
olhar servindo zagueiro naquela agora
ela vai sair pra valer com as pessoas
acham que isso é ver esse tipo de
conteúdo e ideias que se elas querem nós
vamos ver se não estamos desenvolvendo
produtos lácteos que por produto mais
importante que vem dele e que foi a hora
também os quatro que não fazem pressão
constante engraçados
este é um como é que como é que nós e
depois acabámos por conseguir trazer
magenta
a plataforma está foi uma colega que é o
abandono lovers que consegue espalhar a
mensagem com uma força maior que o segue
e mesmo sendo um de nós e pra falar do
nosso produto justamente quando o
produto com carros de chico em contato
com as plataformas e o nosso produto
parece lá muito mais pela visão deus e
este posto específico era onde eram
locais de em que se criam comeram um
cachorro um pouco indeciso e podiam
comer coisas diferente em avaré e e
suposto gerou um um volume total de
negócios é um ponto de interesse dos
americanos e funcionários até o final e
dizer o joão para o reino está fazer não
sei o quê mas para já não atendia o
trekker abaixo do dos han e para para
joão para não pode ser mais por causa de
um posto e as outras empresas mesmo
assim que era dodô hambúrgueres
dancinhas tiveram o mesmo problema já o
que está acontecendo até que descobrem a
globo lança uma publicação do jornal
e é isso que nós vamos fazer pensar nem
sempre nós temos aqui na certa mas ela
existe
então se encontramos aqui dar certo
basta e falarmos com com essa comunidade
e arranjar um conjunto que seja
interessante esta publicação e não
conseguir
nos números mas teve 328 partilhas
chegou a 89 mil pessoas
é brutal o número de pessoas que
conseguimos atingir com o foco são elas
que vão partilhar sobre nós temos
admirado e partilhem com que façam isto
ela disse nós não somos chatos no
facebook
nós não pedimos nada ninguém acha que o
conteúdo deve sempre partir da nossa
estratégia é muito pouco e tirar nunca
perdi custa muito muito muito caro que é
o nosso tempo investirmos muito muito
tempo a estratégia de comunicação e
criação de conteúdos enfim aí que
estamos muito certos aí promoção
propriamente lida uma dois anos neste
momento talvez dois anos poderia no
máximo que não é todos os dias se um dia
tivermos uma boa comunicação nem sequer
fazer só tem três fazer promoção
se tivermos algo interessante para
promover e como é que nós não víamos
isso o primeiro lançamento das
publicações depois setembro torno dos
nossos pais é esse o caminho para chegar
à margem sul nossos a nossa publicação
tem zero de integração nós não pagamos
nada disto foi completamente o rap é o
lá ninguém gosta desta publicação no
banco promoveu e não não promovemos e
não estamos nem é e deixar fazemos uma
diferença clara neste momento fazemos
uma aposta muito muito muito forte e fez
o parto que seja um negócio de cafeteria
loja tudo o que está gerando negócios de
turismo uma aposta muito clara ângulo
os resultados têm da plataforma de
frente para comunicar produtos
diferentes não vale a pena andar a
espalhar os bandidos e os produtos nas
diversas plataformas não estão lá as
pessoas certas e então nós fazemos essa
divisão na parte da estratégia
muitas vezes pensamos que não cometemos
erros e como temos nós
acho que todos os erros possíveis e
imaginárias alguns deus muito básico na
área da cafeteria nem vou falar porque é
quase assustadora no início era o caos
mesmo em termos de comunicação e por
muito crer
custa me a tepco usou aulas na área é
com temos é que fazer algumas coisas são
pedro ernesto pinto fraxe para nós não
funciona e e foi uma escolha com base
nessa conhecimento do minho na mais
potente mas quer resistir espetacular 0
de interação não fosse um estranho foram
os pais que disseram que queriam e ela
revive as novas e interessantes e com
tempos todos os dias 200 e vamos
aprendendo e vamos adaptar de uma das
coisas que nós fazemos muito é o mesmo
nosso pátio e estou vindo a fazer
perguntas é ser muito perspicaz está
constantemente atento à questão de dizer
aos comentários que eles fazem e tentar
perceber o que é que eles querem porque
muitas vezes não dizer claramente se eu
disser gostam do nosso capitão é que
acontece em agosto
você mentiroso você não gosta e se eu
ouvir agosto lançar mas na prática que
depois não tem negócio e isso tem que
casar ela ouviu se muitas vezes não é
nem de plataforma boa as páginas dos
meus concorrentes em outras comunidades
e ver o que é que usando uma dizer que
eu possa tirar do valor para ele
resultados voltados para nós por muito
que eu chego possa parecer só um sorriso
nós gostamos muito de de partilhar com a
vai com quem nos visita o melhor da vida
e criar um sistema que as pessoas saiam
dava vez a passar um bom tempo que
acabou tarde e se for prestar com zeca
tanto melhor mas se não for por estar
com zeca em frente a uma boate
o nosso propósito de sempre é passar o
que há de melhor em harvard por muitos
levam a aberto um buraco aberto em
estava em que o tanque tem com toda está
aí mas nós não queremos nós com o nosso
caminho não é esse nosso caminho e nós
vamos mostrar o que há de melhor em
havana
mostrando que a união já vai mais
pessoas visitaram a van seguia mais
pessoas próximas etapas
esse é o nosso caminho e acham que
funciona bem porque temos em mãos das
pessoas depois no final de fazer uma
visita a dizer
o al wasl você foi fantástica quer botar
visitava a mãe em outra mesa consegue
sair eu faço outra vez sempre o ano e as
pessoas que gostam desse tipo de
estratégia que nós temos o que deixava
já comum como o passe final
já acabou é hoje é não sair do de
marketing
aquilo que nós chamamos no bullshit isso
no bolso e deixem se de tretas de
produção barata de fazer como se lava
constantes vão fazer sipam silo em mauá
sp
nos centros sociais não deixa de 60 anos
foca se conheçam muito mais oeste
corrente e não percebeu os bons clientes
enquanto enquanto meus números ou mesmo
de pessoas sentimentos não as pessoas
têm sentimentos e hoje quando falava dos
avanços do processo ritmo lembra models
longas das clínicas dentárias que todas
agora neste momento são josé e windows
rio e nos meus filhos e aos incentivos
ou na na apresentação anterior falava se
do dos adeptos do nosso sentimento
problemas ou pensar grande e não só com
a cabeça nos é muito mais cooperação
feitos tanto que as pessoas pensem isso
lembrando as regras muito mais emoção e
muito menos técnica tem a técnica tudo
por trás está em ferramentas têm mas no
final nós das respostas pessoas são só a
gente sabe que o zeca é o joão é a
cadeia santana e maria bonita
o que nós temos só uma passagem de cinco
pontinhos você nunca se podem esquecer
nessa estratégia se tiver que fazer
alguma estratégia lembra centro social
entreter e educar e formar resolver
problemas e inspirar se conseguiria
fazer isso na nossa rede social e vejam
em uma delas passa por promover uma
vendendo só fazer um bom trabalho
levando assim obrigado